i was very concerned to hear that you
got kovid in november
and i'm glad to see you looking well
tell us about that experience
right after we did the podcast it
couldn't have been a few days later
don't point at me i didn't give it to
you no you did not give it to me
and um i got caught i did another
podcast
chris the stefano giannis pappas so they
had done
something between that you know i like
to i like to name my you know
i don't like to hide behind and so i
went home
and they said i started feeling terrible
next you know i was struck
with covet and what does it feel like
stricken i it feels like what everybody
says you can't smell
you can't taste and then um
you just feel horrible but luckily for
me i had a heart attack two years before
so i was eligible to get the infusion
who says
you know i've never heard someone say
luckily i had a heart attack two years
ago
no one says that colin except you but
that put you on a special list that
meant you got the infusion of the
antibodies right
yes i had the antibodies infusion so you
know
and it was uh so that really did work i
have to say
a few days later i was better but here's
the problem
i gave it to my wife
so even though i was feeling better she
wasn't eligible for the infusion
she was feeling terrible so
not only did i have to not only to
change the power dynamic of the whole
relationship of course
but i had to walk around and act like i
wasn't that much better
you know what i would have done cohen i
would have walked around the house and
said you know what feels good
those antibodies man
those feel good what do you think
do you think this is good because
there's a trend in comedy that's been
around for a long time where if you
experience a difficulty
they say it's good for comedy because
then you can talk about it in your act
is having covid and you survived it and
you're well now is that gonna be good
for your comedy in any way
yeah i think i can use it the way like
if somebody's uh
tries to medically appropriate and talk
about covet
i'm gonna be like you really shouldn't
talk about it unless you're a covet
survivor
like myself so yeah it's medical
appropriation
but what i'm going to do is i'll
probably i'll do my acting like 20
minutes in
i'll do a couple of covert jokes
everyone's laughing and i'll be like
this
i um i had covered
last november and then just take
you know what i mean that's part of the
show room gets really quiet
yeah right and i go and it's it and this
way you do like two minutes of intro
before you get to another joke
it's interesting because people what
they say about covert it's
and then just go into like some
nonsensical rant
that saves me two minutes of joke
writing and then you're a joke
and everyone's like oh obliged to laugh
he had covert you were probably thinking
about all of this
as you were coming down with kovid you
were thinking i see how i'm going to use
this
i see how i'm going to use this in my
comedy act all i was thinking of
was the the the revenge i would get upon
the people that gave it to me
you know who gave it to you yes
i told you i was on a podcast you know
you never finished your sentence
colin you finish one of every nine
sentences what you said is ah i'll tell
you who i was on a
well i was on a well you see how it goes
no you never told us
i know you know it's fine
i know i know no because
i was talking about with stand-up comedy
it's really been the bane of my
existence
my material is you know great my
delivery
has been very uh like very
jarring for people and i've never
realized i never realized it my whole
career you know
so easily even when you were a young
comic starting out
you you and doing stand-up you had this
pattern
this focal pattern of maybe starting a
sentence but maybe not completely
finishing it
yes and i would finish it like a
throwaway
so because i was doing that it
i i've only realized this recently
because for years people would critique
it
and i'd be like come on but i realized i
made the audience
work as much as i worked on stage
people come out for a nice relaxing
night of comedy
and they're gonna sit back oh no they're
gonna sit back
have a few drinks and listen to a show
no
i made them have to go through the
torture that i have to go through
of thinking changing lanes in the middle
and i guess for a lot of people
that's not their idea of a good time
that's not entertaining
you you like to make your audience write
the second part of the joke for you
that's what you like
well i like to make them think that
they're into what i'm thinking
when i get to it they're like yes we're
on the same page
got it